ciao a benvenuto abetting you owe me
bozo
the other new are the promise of secure
or even a low real common so that's
where sprechen he'll now the reason i'm
demonstrating my limited linguistic
skills is to try to get you to consider
the brexit talks from the other side and
show how the pledge might even be seen
in Italy France or Germany because
anyone who thinks the euro zone is a
land of lay and who need is deluded in
Germany Angela Merkel's embattled and
creaking coalition close to collapse
after the party which props her up lost
lost badly in the Bavarian elections on
Sunday they'd been in power there since
1950 but in part lost as much of the
electorate swung to the anti-immigrant
8ft
in France one-time liberal poster boy
Emmanuel macron now has his lowest
popularity rating ever and near bankrupt
Italy has a government led by a party
set up less than 10 years ago by former
comedian now I've not even mentioned
Austria and Hungary in the grip of
far-right parties and Spain and Greece
who so close to economic collapse Europe
is in flux and increasingly gripped by
far-right ideologies that loathe the
idea of the EU so perhaps those EU
leaders might care to focus on problems
in their own back Giardino I genuinely
think there'll be a lot of people in the
European Union looking at us with a lot
of envy alright the Bluestone they're
doing the right thing we lot of people
in France which they had a friend
affects it is it ok and that sort of
stuff ok to brand people that just want
to get their own nationality an identity
back as far right I think this a bit
he's a bit too much do not mean I'm not
far-right in any way shape or form in
fact nothing brains to everything that's
been thrown at me and and and rightly so
so all I want to see is I stand on our
own two feet as a country it's if you
don't want it like this
it's easier to keep a small bread made
than what it is a massive one you know I
mean so you can look after yourselves a
lot better as an individual is what you
can when you're trying to concentrate
you just look after yourselves and then
you can do all your dealing and
shenanigans around that but number one
the most important
nice to me is the UK just saying I think
I think you're right I think there's a
lot of people looking and going that's
not a bad idea I mean I wish we should
never go that Trevor do you think
perhaps some of the EU leaders need to
look at home look back home well I was
about to say octal I don't really agree
with Phil I mean look after yourself is
fine but you and I both been in the
playground and frankly when there's a
big gang over there called China and a
big going over there called America what
you need to do is not stand about going
oh I'm I'm on my own you get your gang
of your own but but on Nick's point I
think he has a really important point
I'm a remainer everybody knows that but
if somebody come to me clean and said do
you want to join a club a third of whose
members don't really want to be in it
and the court of whose members basically
want people color out of the room I
think I would have swallowed pretty hard
I think there is quite a big issue here
I mean bridge is not that important to
everybody else I have to be honest and
say the German and French don't really
give up let me think about they moved it
maybe moved on but I do think there is
and they see that we have to think about
about the way that the rest of the
continent is moving it's a warning to us
by the way I mean we've been lucky and
we've done well to keep out of that
stream but the mood and the sentiment on
the continent the Swedes for heaven's
sake one in five of them voted for a
party which acknowledges its Nazi roots
doesn't hide the Swedes which was always
a social democrats answer to how
everything will be wonderful if we if we
go to the center-left
let's before we bring in a fuerte you
mentioned Nazis can i play you this clip
please this is Sky News correspondent
Diana Magnay speaking with a neo-nazi
him after we see this clip so I
mean this clearly says I love Hitler and
88 is known to be a number that
represents Hitler in the third life are
you are you saying that doesn't say
Hitler didn't things off you don't think
so no you could have chosen other
letters
yeah and her idea yeah you could have
chosen Germany Sky News correspondent
Diana Magnay speaking to tommy Frank a
neo-nazi according to Germany's domestic
intelligence aging agency and that was
shot at his pub and shop you see
something like that effort that was
specific context because it's illegal in
Germany to support so I can see I mean
that was ludicrous he can't say that
because it's a criminal offense that's
my worry about the far-right I knew I
mean you're preaching to the choir when
you talk about being worried about the
far I'm horrified by what's happening at
Hungary Austria Sweden and Italy know
this goes on well I think that there are
big questions it's not just Europe is
not just Western or Eastern Europe the
entire world is experiencing look at
India got Australia a popular surge and
I think that has a lot to do and I've
said this before with globalization with
the fact that we have had huge social
change the identities have been
globalized and people don't have
globalized senses of identity they have
national or local or ethnic identities
and they want to see that reflected in
in the way that they live and I think
that is a problem that our governments
haven't answered and I think it's a big
problem but I think I feel like you're
conflating a few things because first of
all not all of European move not all the
European movements wants to leave the EU
I mean Italy talked about one scintilla
and changed its mind even marine lepen
talks about herself as a European and
Germany well the the CS you've lost
support in Bavaria but they lost it
primarily to the Greece agrees to do
well not aft but the AFT election might
came out of nowhere in there no denying
the trend of the far-right across Europe
I think the issue for someone like me as
a remainer as well is that I'm not a
huge fan of the EU you know the reason
that I didn't want to leave is not
because I get up every day and love that
you I think it's got lots of very deep
structural problems it's just that our
reasons for leaving make me very
suspicious I should have said by the way
I didn't know this but I looked it up
the eight-eight we saw in that clip is
Heil Hitler
I hate Hitler it's the 8th play yeah
it's a yeah yeah age 8 so that's high
high so just for the viewing what was
the 88 or 88 is Heil Hitler
yeah that guy's obviously Justin
everyone knows what that what that means
and what it says and I think that's
disgraceful I don't think there should
be any place in today's society for
those kind of views I think they're they
just what's from terrible we'd all agree
with that we don't want anybody
wandering around those - well I've
created that in Germany do you think
well first of all I I think that we've
got to be really careful that we don't
conflate because I agree with fail if
you are anti-eu you're not necessarily
far right it's if you've got concerns
about you know how your local city or
whatever in Sweden I'm quoting Germany
we've moved that is dangerously far
right it's dangerous
sweet'n what's happening in Germany 10%
of AFD that guy that we've just seen for
example that is far-right that is
concerning and that has no place in any
society and anyone that supports
somebody like that literally needs to
give their head a shake you can always
find what you have missing what you're
missing with respect is that people who
are voting for some of these far-right
parties know that's the background I
mean that's a problem ten years ago what
you said would have would have made
people laugh those parties out of court
but today people knows Sweden Democrats
they know that the AFD they know that
Golden Dawn and Greece have that sort of
person in them and that background and
they are still voting for them and why
to reapply
why do I do use it as what I'm trying to
get out why well I think that the
problem at partly what eff was said but
I think that there's a more immediate
cause which is that we haven't really
focused in the right way on the speed
and scale of the way that migration has
affected Europe and the differences that
it is brought for us people the Germans
interestingly are spending twenty
billion euros a year on integration
programs because I think they have quite
rightly got that what is important here
is not how many immigrants how how well
people are prepared to receive them and
how they
fit in and I think motive Europe has got
this wrong it's got itself all worked up
about the numbers but not about how we
deal with ethnic and cultural difference
on the ground here